origine de ce festival c'est thierry qui
un jour ont déjeuné ensemble m'a dit est
ce que tu es prêt pour faire un festival
moi je dis bien sûr ok
faisons quelque chose donc on est parti
c'est au mois de mars d'une feuille
blanche et c'est comme ça qu'on a
commencé à monter sur le festival qui à
son apogée ce soir avec la cérémonie
d'ouverture
tv fil 78 pour produisait de plus en
plus de documentaires des programmes
longs des programmes de réflexion je
trouvais que la meilleure façon de
valoriser ses documentaires c'était de
créer un festival dans dix cinémas ce qu
il peut avoir un moment d'échangé avec
le public ce n'est pas le cas avec la
télévision d'où l'idée de proposer des
documentaires bien sûr des films et bien
sûr qu'ils ne sont pas stériles autour
d'un festival avec des remises de prix
et surtout en intégrant non seulement
des salles de cinéma mais également
d'autres partenariats
la médiathèque vs culot mais ce cumul
des librairies
voilà donc faire vraiment un événement
vivant sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est vrai qu'on était parti comme zé
thierry sur faire un festival du film
documentaire
cette année c'était normal de se
raccrocher à l'environnement de la fin
de l'année et notamment à tout ce qui se
passait en france avec la coop 21 donc
très naturellement on a orienté son fils
ce premier festival du film documentaire
sur des documentaires liés à
l'environnement
c'est une première édition qui s'était
quasiment sans budget et sans permanent
donc l'idée c'était de voir l'appétence
à la fois du public y avait également
des équipements des salles de spectacles
des salles de cinéma etc pour voir si ça
répondait à une attente ses amis de
l'ouverture c'est 470 personnes la salle
est pleine on va voir sur l'ensemble des
autres événements il ya 50 événements
saint quentin c'est 50 moment pour un
festival
donc on fera un bilan après on verra
s'ils ont reconduit le
le festival voilà essayer de faire plus
de films documentaires encore sur
d'autres groupes d'autres sites
on aimerait faire des choses notamment
avec le cnc au niveau du site de brodard
si les archives du film relate un de
partenariat qui se met 30 là je l'espère
silos du festival un sur sept